il y a pas qu'un problème au sein de la
majorité présidentielle il y a aussi un
problème au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale entre les centristes et les
républicains autour de ce fameux article
3 est-ce que les débats pourraient
conduire à une espèce de division une
nouvelle fracture au sein du groupe bah
je crois que c'est aussi une épreuve de
vérité effectivement pour la MAJ pour
pour les gens qui se réclament de la
majorité satoriale nous avons des
élections à venir bientôt dans 6 mois où
Emmanuel Macron sera le principal
opposant d'une droite qui est
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition euh et je
dirais il ne s'agit pas d'être bête et
méchant en disant parce que ça vient
d'Emmanuel Macron est contre il y a bien
une règle de fond derrière il y a il y a
un sujet on peut pas depuis des années
expliquer que nous avons un problème
d'immigration irrégulière expliquer que
nous avons déjà 500000 réfugiés sur
notre territoire nous avons 10 %
d'étrangers c'estàdire le double de ce
qu'il y avait il y a 50 ans com bien
Julien Bert quand vous dites moment de
vérité ça veut dire que vous demandez au
sénateurs centristes de clarifier leur
position par Emmanuel moi je suis pas en
état si vous voulez de réclamer quoi que
ce soit au Sénat c'est au sénateur si
vous voulez de voter en leur àâ et
conscience mais je crois qu'il ce serait
une un très mauvais signal de voter un
texte avec cet article 3 parce que cet
article 3 dit l'in même viidé de sa
substance parce que là il y a un
compromis qui se dessine sur un article
3 un peu un peu vidé de sa substance
attention alors là encore on garde le
parce que d'abord il je vois deux deux
inconvénients à ce qui est proposé
actuellement premièrement cet article 3
fa voir que nous ne vivons pas dans un
monde clos il y a des gens qui sont dans
des pays d'immigration qui ont la télé
qui ont Internet et qui suivent nos
échanges et ils sont souvent d'ailleurs
mieux informés que nous-même sur la
nature des débats et donc pourquoi c'est
un article qui est problématique parce
qu'en fait il dit venez en France nous
avons des besoins nous avons des métiers
en tention et si vous venez sur ces
métiers entention nous allons vous
régulariser c'est donc le fait paspirant
et puis deuxièmement parce que on veut
mettre dans la loi un mécanisme qui
aujourd'hui relève d'une circulaire ce
qui va être un nid à contentieux parce
qu'à partir du moment où c'est fixé dans
la loi et que les préfets vont appliquer
la loi et bien vous aurez des recours
alors qu'une circulaire bien par
définition c'est une espèce de tolérance
qui est donné par rapport à l'état du
droit